The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: I've
handed out a guide
to what we're going
to cover today.
Now, I don't know how familiar
you are with the material.
Does anybody, for instance,
have any familiarity
with what is called
space syntax?
How much familiarity?
STUDENT: I saw a
presentation that someone
who is working in
England on space syntax
gave to the National Capital
Park and Planning Commission
in DC.
JULIAN BEINART: And?
STUDENT: It was
pretty interesting.
JULIAN BEINART: When
was this, recently?
Or--
STUDENT: Yeah, 2011 I think.
JULIAN BEINART: Do the
book Space is a Machine?
STUDENT: No.
Is that what the
reading was from?
JULIAN BEINART: No, this
is a voluminous document.
It costs a lot of money to buy.
STUDENT: [LAUGHS]
JULIAN BEINART: Ah.
It really is more of an
expansion of the space syntax
methodology and the idea than
we have time for in this class.
That's why I ask if anybody
is familiar with it.
OK.
This is the last class
in the first section.
And we're concentrated
again, very, very briefly,
as we did on Tuesday,
with theories
which seem to be determined by
the logic from social science.
There are microtheories
within each
of these, lots of rules of
thumb, lots of understanding
which is not externalized
theoretically.
For instance, one
of my favorites
is Fifth Avenue and Park Avenue.
A section through a building
on Fifth Avenue, a section
of a building on Park Avenue.
On Fifth Avenue, the
ground is significant.
Everything that is
built is connected
to the ground by
mechanical systems,
generally an escalator
for five or six floors.
The basement is
important because it's
linked to a surface only
one floor from the ground.
Two buildings on Park
Avenue which you know,
Lever Brothers and
Seagram's building.
Lever Brothers gives up
the ground for nothing.
The ground is worthless.
Seagram's building
extends a plaza,
in return for which it gets
more bulk to build taller.
The role of the ground
in these two cases
are the subject of an
economic theory, which
is just the rule of thumb.
It's observed.
I don't know of a rule of--
it's much like, well, other
rules of thumb in our business.
In fact, it's curious.
In a discipline such
as architecture,
there are very few
theoretical texts.
There used to be
How do you learn architecture?
Have you got a textbook?
You can't learn science
without a textbook.
A textbook is the agreed-upon
synthesized material
which you need to know.
I make this preface because some
of the theoretical propositions
we will look at today suffer
from the same difficulty.
But they, unlike the series
which we looked at on Tuesday,
where space was either
neutral, or costly,
or friction-producing, or
a measure for recording
a distribution of some process--
most of what we feel to be true
and experience with the city
is lost.
None of the social
science theories--
with the exception,
perhaps, of the first one,
which we discussed--
has any connection to
valuing the built environment
as something in itself.
Kevin Lynch is the first of the
protagonists of a theory which
deals with equality of
the built environment
en masse, not a single building,
but a system of buildings.
Lynch starts his work--
there's an of Lynch's work at
MIT just down the corridor.
If you have time one day and
you have nothing else to do,
look at his notebook on
his first visit to Italy
when he was a young
professor here at MIT.
He does a detailed drawing
of the path system linking
the major squares and piazza,
the piazza and churches,
beautifully drawn.
At the end of his four
or five days in Florence,
he writes a note.
Why did I not ask
the people what
they do on Saturday nights?
What about the
activity in this town?
Why don't I take
that into account?
Then he leaves Florence.
His preoccupation with trying to
understand the spatial pattern
of cities through
asking people is
evident in his first book,
The Image of the City.
What is the image of the city?
The image of the city is
made up of three items.
What are the three?
You've read the book, I presume.
STUDENT: There's
the experiment where
they ask people on the street.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes,
and I didn't ask you
for ho the study was done.
I asked you, what are the
three abstract components?
I'll tell you-- identity,
structure, and meaning.
That equals image.
And you find this out
by cognitive mapping,
by asking people how they
find their way around cities--
Los Angeles, New York,
Boston, and so on.
What Lynch could not do in that
study was deal with meaning.
It's significant that the power
that The Image of the City book
had escapes the one
component which bedevils us
in our valuation of much
of the built environment,
and that's meaning.
Kevin apologized twice
in different publications
for his inability to
deal with meaning.
I say that as a beginning
to a discussion of his work.
When, in this class,
we asked people,
when he was teaching here
with me, what they remembered
of the book, they would
say landmarks, Z, Z, Z,
a set of alphabetical items.
And then says, that's not
what I wrote the book for.
I wrote the book
to make it clear
that if you want to know
something about a city,
you have to ask the
people who live in it,
not take formulaic
generalizations.
Of course, he was being
a bit harsh on himself.
But his last book--
I must say, one of the
things about all the theories
that I'll be discussing
today is that they've
published the ideas.
They're not hermeneutic.
They're not hermetic.
They're not sealed
off from examination.
In architecture, so much of
knowledge is internalized.
Your sensibility to
patterns is built up
through much of the
practice of priesthood.
Lynch and the others today--
by the way, the others
today will be in order--
Kevin Lynch, Christopher
Alexander, John Habraken,
space syntax.
And then last, we'll look at
the work of the British Land Use
and Built Form group in
Cambridge, England, Lionel
March.
Sir Lionel March.
Oh, no, and he wasn't knighted.
Sorry just Lionel March.
For Lynch, the
problem remains that--
let me see if I
can find a phrase.
No, there isn't one
phrase that I can
find which sums up his search.
What I'll do with him is
go through the performance
of dimension theory, which is
the last one, which he built up
in this class and which is
published in a book which
was called A Theory
of Good City Form
and then appeared late as Good
City Form, and use that as--
and then I will compare
that with his writings
on a utopian speculation
that he made, just to give
some embodiment to his ideas.
Some generalizations--
unlike Christopher Alexander
and John Habraken, Lynch's
work is not a critique
of contemporary urbanism.
His philosophy is in relation
to present-day city and time.
He is completely interested in
the complexity and difficulty
we have understanding
of the form of a city.
He believes there are ranges of
understanding, not standards.
His theory,
performance dimension,
set up ranges within which
different cultures could
construct their own standards
and which the dimensions could
be compared one to
another and then balanced
again two meta-criteria,
justice and application.
Lynch's humanism comes
from his appreciation
of one of the major dimensions
of the human system,
and that's its
capacity to learn.
And therefore, his
ideal utopia is
a manifestation of
human beings' ability
to change culture
and aspirations
rather than the manifestation
of some iron law.
There's no drawing
in his utopia.
It's partly because
of his decision
that architecture
doesn't help much
in understanding urban form.
I recall a disagreement I
had in this class with him
when I introduced Aldo
Rossi's book, which
was new at the time.
And Lynch was very angry.
And he writes about the
denouncement of Aldo Rossi.
I tried to argue that there
was some merit in Rossi's
speculation as an
architect and so on.
I don't understand why Lynch
disparaged architecture
as such.
He didn't disparage
architecture as a discipline.
He disparaged the method
in which architects
took upon themselves
the right to invent
spatial ideas on their own--
again, without consultation.
Lynch was so aghast at the
idea of an imperial rulership
of knowledge and
hesitated every time
to embrace something unless
it had been acknowledged
by human experience.
Many of these people whose
theories I talking about today
are very much rooted in
observing existing patterns
and building on them.
They differ in
respect to the way
in which they observe
these patterns, what
they make of them.
I will show you that in
Christopher Alexander's pattern
language, he makes
absolutely derivations
from his observation
of human behavior.
John Habraken never makes
a categorical, good or bad.
John Habraken believes
that all agreements
are good because they are
saturated with information
from culture and so on.
Lynch wishes to build
a model for the world
as if urbanism was at the
beginning of its trajectory.
He believes that, in
the model of science,
that science started
from nowhere.
It kept on repeating
experiments, developing
new and new identity,
and new and new ideology,
and reaching a point where it
was much more sophisticated
than where it began.
So he starts off by
setting out the dimensions
that you had to take.
This is Kepler looking
at this, trying
to derive a theory of
the Earth's movement.
Lynch is trying to set forth,
what are the things that you
have to take into
account and measure
in order to have a
comprehensive view of a city
independent of which
place in the world it is,
independent of which culture?
He experiments
with these and has
a set of ideas which he
writes about which set up
the prologue to these ideas.
I gave you, in the handout
today, one of these subideas.
It was the notion
of adaptability.
Again, adaptability
would interest Lynch
because it is the capacity
of the human being
to change patterns
after learning.
Adaptability in our class
discussion was a separate item.
It became, in the book,
a subset of the item fit.
I gave you this
piece on adaptability
as an example of how he
would ask you to develop it.
He said-- let me find an example
of what I gave to you today.
He tries to break
down adaptability
into subcategories.
Manipulability, which is
different from reversibility.
What is resilience?
What is the innovativeness?
I then added-- in
your thing, I've
given you some handwritten
response from Lynch,
not because that you should
read it, but here is an idea.
He writes this piece
on adaptability.
See, it's circulated.
Somebody, an economist, sends
back a review of his ideas.
And then he replies
to the economist.
This is a handwritten
reply to a colleague.
His imagination is that if
we each, all the students
of urbanism, took on
the task of identifying
in specific terms what these
categories of inevitability,
we would have a basis for
a specific culture settling
an item of reversibility
in specific terms.
Standards would imply
that all of them
are equal for all cultures.
Of course, that's not true.
You could have
varying standards.
But for Lynch, the idea was that
we were in such a rough state,
theoretically, that you had
to set out these items more
systematically.
He didn't get very far.
He died too young.
And if he were here
today, he'd add
more than I'm able to
explain on his behalf.
In his collected works,
there's a chapter
called "A Place, Utopia".
Now, it's interesting
that this place, utopia,
which is his speculation about
what an ideal urban world would
look like--
there's no drawing.
In The Image of the City,
he uses little drawings
on the side of the text to
add information visually.
Here, there's no drawing.
I'll just pick out a couple of
items from "The Place, Utopia".
Has anybody read
"A Place, Utopia"?
We're not wasting my
time, then, or your time.
I propose, he says, to leave--
I attempt something more
modest here without losing
track of society.
I propose to leave it
unaccounted for except where
it springs from some
feature of place.
Everything about what I'm
going to say, he says,
is about how people relate
to their surroundings,
rather than out of a
self-absorbed technical fantasy
or mechanical consequence
of social prescription
on the other.
In other words, what he's saying
is that there are items which
we can learn from
simply from the way
space is used and manipulated.
Imagine an urban countryside,
a highly varied but humanized
landscape.
It is neither urban nor rural
in the old sense since houses,
workplaces are set among
trees, farms, and streams.
Within this extensive
countryside,
there's a network of small,
intensive urban centers.
The countryside
is as functionally
intricate and interdependent
as any contemporary city.
The land, the space is
not allocated to owners.
The use of land is brief
in the history of cities,
so much like we've picked
up from other sources.
It is better for the land to
be in the hands of a trust.
He calls them a
regional land trust.
These tasks grant leases for
the present enjoyment of space.
Everyone is trained to read
a place just as everyone
is trained to read a good book.
There are slow places
and fast places.
I can go through
this in some detail.
But you can read it yourself.
What is significant about it is
that he doesn't start off with
a definition that a city
is anything that cannot be
replicated through a mixture
of landscape and building.
He doesn't depict the building.
He sees, in a trained
society, people
will pick good buildings.
They will make them
from good materials.
His emphasis is on depicting
those spaces in buildings
or infrastructure of
a city which derive
from the goodness of people.
Now, people are not good.
They're good and bad.
Sometimes they are both.
We are all good and
bad in our life.
There's an element in many of
these theorists in depicting
a society without
political friction,
without individual competition.
John Habraken's agreements--
he says good agreements
will be made independent
of whether you're
a Marxist or Capitalist.
You will have to come to some
agreement about where you enter
a building, whether there
is parking underground,
or how many floors of building
there are above ground.
Christopher Alexander also
bypasses the political impact
on his work.
He makes decisions
about patterns
which are not subject
to intercourse
for producing agreements.
These patterns are decided
upon through his examination
of the nature of order.
Alexander has an interesting
trajectory in his work.
His first book, Notes
on the Synthesis of--
I don't know if any of you
have paid particular attention
to Alexander's work.
Has anybody been an
Alexander student?
No.
Christopher Alexander,
when I first ran into him
was at Harvard.
And he had written Notes on
the Synthesis of Form, which
was an admiration and an
attempt to understand how
a culture, such as that
in the Middle East,
could make carpets without
any explicit instruction
as to how to do them, only an
oral tradition, handed down,
but allowing within that
tradition enormous variation
in the maintenance of quality.
He looked to computation
to enable us to,
perhaps, do the
same kind of thing.
Let's maintain quality,
although explicitly unclear
about how we were doing it.
He's moved through a number
of phases in his work.
No sooner did he--
been interested in
optimization, then he
wrote a piece about how
to maximize communication,
a silly piece in which he
argues that in the zoning
of suburban housing, the
living room should be exposed
to the street and curtains would
be unnecessary, that people
would enjoy partaking in
the experience of being
a community, a remark which
might well apply to New York
City but not to an
American suburb.
He then published a
significant paper called--
"The Structure of a
City is Not a Tree."
It was more complicated
than a tree,
didn't have a central
trunk with all its branches
regularly sprouting
from the trunk.
But geometrically, he
couldn't explain what it was.
But he knew it wasn't a tree.
And then-- partly, I think,
because of his living
on the west coast
[CHUCKLES] where, perhaps,
the counterculture has spread
more ideas in American thought
than anywhere else
in the world--
he started arguing that
there was a microunit which
had spatial and social
characteristics, what
he calls patterns.
Each microunit has a pattern.
There are good patterns,
and there are bad patterns.
He studies a field of
spatial and social relations.
There are good, living
patterns; bad, dead ones.
We do not need grand planning
or design for the whole town
if each thing is made
in a context which
the other understands.
The town emerges by itself
and is continually repaired.
He believes that society has--
it's a romantic notion--
has a history of patterns
which are good patterns.
They're good patterns
because they're lived in,
they're understood.
Like Patrick Geddes, he tries--
remember, Patrick Geddes
is the plane diagram
which emotional, objective,
experienced items all
can fold into each other.
Here, Alexander is very much
again trying to link feeling
and thought.
A good pattern is one which
is objectively correct
but is also felt by
you to be correct.
A good example is
in a piece in which
he tries to explain to
a young architecture
student at Berkeley
what he's all about.
He says, look at this table.
They're sitting in a cafe.
It's made of wood.
There's the difference
between making the edge
and finishing the edge of
the wood with sandpaper,
making the minimal transition
from one service to another,
versus the machine-like
one, which our table is,
which has just rounded it off
in a very blunt, crude way.
He asked the student,
which of these two
is a representation
of your good self?
The student doesn't understand
what he's talking about.
Why should the edge
of a table represent
your psychological whole?
I quote, "but what if
I ask you to tell me
which of these two tables
you're more willing to take
as a picture of your own self?
Which of the two would you
consider a better candidate
to picture of your own soul?"
And so on-- everything.
The trouble is that
it's difficult to write
such patterns.
We don't have the tools yet.
We may one day have
them to do that.
These patterns which are
printed in the book, A Pattern
Language, on biblical paper is
almost a giveaway of a kind.
For instance,
Pattern on page 115--
there's abundant evidence to
show that high buildings make
people crazy.
Now, objectively,
this is not true.
There may be reasons why
tall buildings are harmful.
But it is an abstract pattern
or is a theoretical pattern
derived from observation.
It's not true.
I can quote you
from Herbert Gans,
a well-known urban sociologist
who once taught here at MIT.
I quote, "thus, whether housing
is high- or low-rise does not,
by itself, make
much difference."
The luxury apartment
house has been
built in New York City for
well over a century now,
and no one has yet discovered
that the buildings jammed
on Park and Fifth Avenues and
so forth generate pathology.
Conversely, when
poor people live
in even the best-designed
low-rise projects,
they still do not escape
the problems of poverty.
Gans is correct.
Why does Alexander
make such a statement?
He's too intelligent to
know that his statement is
incorrect.
I don't know.
There's a kind of insistence
that either you, in--
when I learned debating, I
was taught that sometimes it's
a good idea to throw out a
statement, an assumption,
a hypothesis just to make the
argument more interesting.
And if your opponent
didn't catch up
on the weakness of your
argument, you would win.
I don't think Alexander's
into debating games.
But it's often puzzled me
why he took the trouble
to assemble often
very good ideas, very
down-to-earth ideas.
He, for instance, says
single designers don't really
produce comprehensive results.
He says, I work in the College
of Environmental Design
at Berkeley, which was designed
by a team of the best highly
trained architects
in our college.
I can't put plants on
the sill in my window
because nobody ever
thought about what
the best position
of the window would
be in the section of the wall.
They pushed the
window to the inside
to allow a maximum of
use on the outside where
there's no need for any use.
Why do intelligent people
make such stupid assumptions?
They never consulted us.
Well, if an architect
were redesigning
MIT's School of Architecture
and asked me about my office,
I don't know if I would
remember to specify
that the window needs to be
on the outside of the wall
to allow me the space on
the inside for my plants
or for whatever.
So his observation is
that somehow, the system
isn't working.
Modern urbanism is a mess.
So he proposes a
number of rules.
I won't go through the rules.
You can see them
in his later book,
A New Theory of Urban Design.
There are rules about growing
a whole, about piecemeal,
unpredictable coherence, full
of feeling, no single artist.
There are many people involved,
the whole idea of a thing
having to have feeling.
The seven rules-- let
me find the one about--
rule number three, visions.
Every project must first be
experienced and then expressed
as a vision which can be
seen in the inner eye.
I don't know where my inner
eye is and how to use it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JULIAN BEINART: It
must have this quality
so strongly that it can also
be communicated to others
and felt by others as a vision.
At least Alexander is attempting
to be explicit about his ideas.
Explicitness is an
advantage in debate.
And explicitness, even
if you make mistakes,
is better than dull hermiticism.
And all of these people
are generating explicitness
as one of the aspects
of their work.
In the handout I
gave to you, there's
a piece from A New Theory
of Urban Design, this.
On the left is a piece
of Rome, a plan of Rome
around the Pantheon,
medieval Rome, as opposed
to an American suburb.
What are the
characteristics of the world
depicted on the left-- a good
world, according to Alexander?
The whole is made up of parts
which are unique but belong
to families of shape.
There are churches, which
all have open space in front
of them-- the Pantheon, and so
on, Sant'Ignazio, Sant'Gesú.
There are patterns of
housing which repeat.
There are decisions which are
made through piecemeal addition
rather than through a ramp
in the industrial production.
There's a family of
belongingness of all the parts.
In a sense-- although I don't
know who had the vision which
produced this plan, I don't
think there was one person,
one pope who said Rome
would be this way--
but there were
patterns, presumably,
which people learned
from other patterns
and decided to reproduce
them in a piecemeal way.
So building up from
experience, building up
from categories of knowledge
which had already been tested,
as opposed to this
machine-like production.
Alexander is tough medicine.
He can come across
as an arrogant fool.
He recently produced
four volumes
called The Nature of Order.
He's even more explicit.
In The Nature of
Order, I have tried
to construct a coherent
picture of life
on Earth which makes sense of
these matters, that gives us
something to live for
and worth living for.
Yes, like Geddes, I am
trying, at the same time,
to deal with the emotional world
and the objective, ordinary
world around us.
What is extraordinary
is he writes
about A Pattern Language.
By about 1975, these
investigations,
which I undertook with five
colleagues, gave us gold.
We discovered about 250
invariant spatial patterns.
Each one was associated
with the stability
of human environmental studies.
They were published
in A Pattern Language.
They have become a standard
part of what is known and used
by architects.
Well, what's this all about?
It's not true.
So why does a man say
something which is not true?
It can only be provocative.
And perhaps like
John McEnroe shouting
at an umpire in
a tennis game, he
had a reason for provoking
response, dealing
with satisfaction of his
inner grief publicly.
I can only, without doing
a psychoanalysis of this,
be surprised by it.
The fact is that architects
seldom read a book
like Pattern Language.
And they're not in the
habit of taking a statement
like "tall buildings are
a danger to human health"
seriously.
One last thing
before we move on--
in his latest work,
he claims that there
are a body of patterns.
I'll use his words.
The idea of how much
life is in things
is subjective in the
sense of observation.
This quality of life
seems to be correlated
with the repeated appearance
of 15 geometric properties.
The appearance of living
structure in things
is also correlated--
so on, and so on.
He's now reduced the
complexity to the repetition
of 15 patterns.
I haven't seen these patterns.
I don't know what they are.
But the observation that
complexity can be reduced to 15
repeated patterns--
they are probably
centrally focused.
I don't know what they are.
He says they are true
in art, in urbanism,
in everything that
speaks of life.
What is it that speaks of life?
I understand that walking
down the street in Italy,
in almost any
small Italian town,
will resonate a certain quality
which evokes being alive.
There's energy.
There's organization.
There's all of the
elements that you
might encounter,
actually or subliminally,
which would say this is lively.
Versus a shopping center
parking lot on Sunday afternoon,
at any time of the week,
would not evoke that.
We can spend a couple of
hours starting to write down,
what would cause you to
experience something as being
alive and something
which wasn't?
I don't know what to say about
the body of work of Alexander.
It's going to be a pity that
he has spent so much energy
and will have such a little
observable impact on the way we
make buildings and make cities.
You are a good test group.
Have you been influenced by
Christopher Alexander's work?
A little bit?
A little bit, yeah.
I would say the same thing.
John Habraken was head of the
Department of Architecture
here at MIT for a
number of years.
When he was in Holland, he wrote
a little book called Supports
in which he argued that there
was a distinction between two
aspects of building.
The one which he called supports
was the infrastructure which
allowed habitation
to take place--
all the pipes, all the
structure, all the material.
And he separated that
from a human capacity--
which, for want
of a better word,
I think his word
was indwelling--
that was the creative
capacity that all people
had to determine their
own microenvironment.
Supports were basic items which
enabled individual creativity.
When he decided to engage
these ideas in a larger world,
he came upon the
idea that the best
way to understand
the actions of a city
were to understand it
is a set of agreements.
Agreements are required
for the production
of any pieces of city.
It's, of course,
not actually true.
But in his view, the agreements
between differing parties,
surprisingly, could
produce environments
in which certain
aspects were agreed upon
and certain aspects
were not agreed upon.
It's difficult to understand
some of his material.
He's written quite widely.
His writings include pieces
like The Control of Complexity,
which is in your reading,
a number of others.
Essentially, his work is best
explicated in a piece of work
he did here at MIT called
The Grunsfeld Variations.
There's a publication of
it available in the MIT
publication list--
I don't know where that is--
a piece of work which
he did with students.
I will use it to
explain, perhaps better,
what his larger ideas are.
The two diagrams you
have in your handout--
the one is a plan of
the Grunsfeld variation,
which is this.
This is a set of
redesigned blocks
in the Back Bay of Boston.
Agreements are
reached that there
will be high-density
but low-rise buildings.
Agreement is reached that there
will be parking underground.
But halfway, there are streets.
And the parking will
be set in such a way
that you can have two
kinds of conditions--
a half-parking level,
a full-parking level,
and variations of
the street height.
I'm not sure that
I remember what
all the other agreements were.
He then says we can learn
from the tissue of this area.
Exactly what he's
learned, I don't know.
It's not-- you have to look
at each of these projects
to understand what.
But you can see in
the diagrams, there
are tendencies to reproduce the
length of facades and so on.
What he argues is
that here are a set
of different interpretations of
a similar set of instructions.
They all describe a
variety of outcomes
based on the same
agreements, meta-agreements.
In the little diagram, which I
handed out to you by student,
extending the physical
structure of a small town
in Ladakh, in northern India,
he does these exercises
with students, in which you
start off with a basic theme.
The theme is what the culture
is already reproducing.
You understand the
variations that
are possible on that
theme, what agreements have
to be made to extend the items
in different ways, what becomes
private, what becomes public,
what is negotiated, and so on.
And it sets up a pattern
which can grow over time
with new agreements made
for the use of roofs
as the density grows and so on.
There are two problems
with Habraken's work.
One, again, it is
essentially apolitical.
I don't mean politics
in the Democratic Party
versus Republican Party sense.
I meant in the notion that
all agreements turn out
to be responsible outcomes.
I don't know what--
Habraken is using
a methodology which
distinguishes the
existing form of Amsterdam
from the new extension of
Amsterdam by modern architects.
Habraken claims that it's
the modern architects who
have lost all of the
understanding of what
agreements are.
He doesn't specify what
bad agreements are.
Habraken doesn't do this
on Long Island, where
there may be waste
space, buildings
in the middle of sites with
open space around them.
These are all dense,
built-together systems,
much like the original plans
and the early expansions
of the city of Amsterdam.
So I don't know what--
I can't explain the strategy.
The strategy is that,
again, like Alexander, you
learn from what exists.
You use your discerning capacity
to build on what exists.
You don't-- in Alexander's case,
when he did Oregon experiment,
he said, we will not build
individual large buildings all
by themselves.
In the program, for every
large building of classrooms,
you need 10% of shops.
You need 5% of open space.
You need 20% of housing.
All of these patterns
are breaking down
programs, which are
large and mononuclear,
into complex patterns and
repeated in small parts,
in small spatial entities.
These people have--
John Habraken has gone quite
far in developing technologies
for user situations
in support systems.
But both Alexander
and Habraken's notions
are intellectually
very responsible.
They are conservative.
I don't know what you do
when you build a new town.
You don't have
any infrastructure
to build a contrapuntal
system around.
And I'm sure that
that can be resolved
by assuming a set of
agreements early on,
based on some ingredients
from the broader
culture of the place and so on.
We've got a few minutes to touch
on a different set of stories.
Billy Hillier and
Julienne Hanson
wrote a book called The Social
Logic of Space in which they
argued, essentially, that
the spatial pattern which
surrounds us affects us.
They argued a lot
against the notion
of architectural determinism,
which argues that architecture
determines our lives.
They showed that only
under certain conditions
does the spatial pattern
really have effects.
The space syntax-- syntax
is a word from linguistics.
It refers to the proper order
of words in a sentence in order
for it to make sense.
In some languages, the
verb precedes the noun--
I eat a fish.
In other languages--
I, the fish, eat.
Each has a syntax
which makes sense.
And linguists can probably
explain the reasons
why one system works and
the other doesn't work.
The work that has been
known as space syntax
really is more recent.
It's the work which is
published in this book,
Space is the Machine, which
is an extensive document.
And if any of you are
interested in this idea,
you should probably try
to read parts of it.
Essentially, the argument
is that behavior--
that you need to understand
the space of the city
before you can understand
any of its elements.
The space of the city,
in the application
of this space syntax
model, is a theory
based upon movement patterns.
Crudely speaking, they say that
the movement pattern in a city
is a function of the pattern
that is shaped in order
to cause the movement or
that allows the movement
to take place.
So in a town which has
space for movement,
they can distinguish
in what they
call high correlation, which
is the number of connections
that are possible with a minimum
number of separate moves.
And low correlation
represents a change of pattern
which involves the
maximum number of moves.
I'm putting it rather crudely.
By this, you can
characterize the layout
of a town in terms of this
capacity of movement to flow.
They were correlating encounter
rates with a space syntax
methodology.
In other words, if you wish to
create a system in which there
are random encounter
acts, it was not only
a function of density.
It's a function,
also, of pattern.
And it's also-- although they're
a little unclear about this,
it's not so clearly a result of
a particular land use pattern.
If Marlene Dietrich was
singing tonight in east Boston,
I might go to east Boston.
I wouldn't normally
go to east Boston.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JULIAN BEINART: But
then the argument
would be that Marlene Dietrich
would sing in a space which
is easily available to me.
Andres Sevtsuk, who did
his PhD here two years ago,
has taken some elements
of the space syntax model
and correlated it with
patterns of movement
and commercial
location in Cambridge.
It's a branching
off of space syntax.
It's not really space
syntax because it doesn't
develop theoretical models.
He just bases it on
observation, a very fine,
detailed observation.
The value of space
syntax, presumably,
is in its correlation with
social good dimensions.
So for instance, the
analysis of spatial patterns
would suggest that crime rates
are much lower where there
is a high encounter rate, so
that housing estates which
turn their backs on to
conventional streets
and have their access from
private, unguarded domains
in the center, are
much more likely to be
available for
burglary and others.
And this correlates.
Their work is
expanded enormously.
They have now have
computer programs which
you can buy and play yourself.
They consult all over the world.
I have shown you one of the
little projects in one drawing.
That's the Trafalgar
Square problem.
Now, you can say that
everything that they've
built as a theoretical model
and what they've actually
found on the ground
is something that you,
as an intelligent
observer, could have told.
There's something obvious about
what this enormous investment
of energy and mind produces.
I was always told
when I studied--
there's an class in
urban sociology at Yale--
that I should understand
that sociology
is about everyday things and
that you shouldn't be surprised
if sociological conclusions
accompany everyday observation.
I don't know.
It's a question which
critics of space syntax
have been very
frequent to say, why
waste the money on something
which produces nothing new
and just confirms what
you can intuitively know?
If there are obstacles
to where people can walk,
people won't walk there--
to reduce it to a rather,
sort of base level.
It had a-- what do you think
of the presentation you heard?
STUDENT: The one thing that I
thought was interesting was,
towards the end, he was
proposing they were going to--
if you were to redevelop over
the train yards in London.
And he showed if you
just put a grid down
where the potential
commercial streets would be,
because they
color-map the streets.
JULIAN BEINART: Sure, sure.
STUDENT: And he said, but
if you did this pattern,
then you can see, oh,
this, according to him,
would probably make a really
good commercial street.
And these would be residential.
It's sort of a way to
quantitatively understand
non-grid patterns in a way that
you could present to a planning
board or a government.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
STUDENT: It was interesting.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah, the
adjustments to the King's Cross
site plan were interesting.
I think a couple of things.
Number one, it satisfies me when
somebody methodologically shows
that the form of things
has meaning, has value.
If you think that high encounter
rates are a good thing,
at least they will tell
you how to accomplish it.
And that's not a bad
set of propositions.
We understand, actually, very
little about high encounter
rates.
We assume them to be good.
And Manhattan has had a history
of, since its early days,
making sure that sidewalks
on its major avenues
are wide enough to
take a lot of people.
Tokyo hasn't.
The sidewalks are too narrow
for the pedestrian volume.
And one could imagine
that the encounter rates--
the difficulty about
encounter rates
is that, often, people use them
to believe that that is good.
Richard Sennett, I
think, naively believes
that it's good for
public relations.
When I walk down Fifth Avenue,
I don't stop and talk to a woman
with a fur and a dog.
I'd probably be shot
or be accused of--
you know.
Crowds are not naturally
places which enable--
often, they don't enable
human communication.
So encounter rates
are, in themselves,
not absolute good
or absolute bad.
But certainly, the
notion that you feel--
when do you feel safer?
In all cultures, when
you are on streets
with a lot of other people--
I can imagine.
I've been in places
where I've been
shit-scared of
being on the street
with a lot of other
people because they all
look like criminals to
me, because I couldn't
read the situation well enough.
The last set of stuff
has a body of literature.
And I've only chosen one page
from one of the documents.
There's a good book called Urban
Space and Structures, which
those of you serious about
becoming urban designers
need to read.
It's edited by Leslie Martin
and Lionel March, Cambridge
University Press, 1972.
The British have been
interested in understanding
spatial patterns largely
through geometry.
In the piece that I've
given to you today,
on the right-hand
side is a section
of the grid of New York from
42nd to 52nd and from Eighth
Avenue to Park Avenue.
The argument is
relatively simple.
If you took the amount
of gross square footage
built on this parcel in
the black areas today,
and you took away a
number of the streets--
he took away every second
street, more or less--
you could rebuild the same
amount of square footage
in the pattern on the right
with only a maximum height
of seven floors and large
amounts of open space inside.
Now, no architecture
student I know of
would come to that
conclusion automatically.
It's much like the use
of the Fresnel lens
in arguing population in a city.
As you go outwards, if you
want the same area of land,
as you get further
out, these bands
need to become thinner because
the area they cover is larger.
So the total population
in the center of the city
can be housed in a thin
band on the outside.
This is not-- there's a
diminishing amount of width
required in each band as you
go further out because the band
becomes larger.
It's a simple
geometric observation
which they apply
to some estimates
about urban population.
The number of books published--
I will come back to
the work of this group
when we talk about prediction
of growth and flexibility
of building apparatus.
A lot of this work came from
a set of investigations that
the British did at the
end of the '39-'46 war
in the rebuilding of British
infrastructure-- hospitals,
universities, and so on.
I will do a series
of case studies
of a number of university
plans showing two factors--
one, the idea that new groups of
knowledge disciplines cohered--
microbiology as opposed
to microphysics, biology
and chemistry mixing
together, and so on--
how these patterns
could be accommodated
in physical form which required
the least adjustment over time.
We will look at the Technical
University in Berlin.
We will look at MIT as examples
of these patterns which
maintain-- which promote
high degrees of flexibility.
Also, in the British
writing about hospitals,
the research done in hospitals.
Knowing that hospitals
change hospital science
and the administration
changes rapidly,
how would you choose
patterns which
enabled the minimum disruption
in the trajectory of change?
So if any of you are interested
in this kind of work,
this is not the class to take.
I can just tell you.
We'll touch on some
of this later on.
But I can just read you
some of the list of books
this comes from.
There's Philip
Steadman's book called
Architectural Morphology.
There's Philip Steadman's
book The Evolution of Design.
There's Lionel March and Philip
Steadman's book The Geometry
of Environment, MIT Press, 1974.
There's a couple of the
more generally applied
outcomes of much of this work.
We've finished the
first part of the three
sections of this class.
This first part
was just an attempt
to bring you up to speed on
some things which you might not
have known about.
We start the serious work on--
what is today?
Tuesday.
We start the serious
work on Thursday.
We will start excavating the
spatial pattern of existing
cities after the
Industrial Revolution.
We'll, on Thursday,
try to make sense
of what industrialism
meant, what
it meant to spatial patterns
in cities, what it meant
to the invention of
new instruments--
the mortgage system,
deficit spending, and so
on, the advent of poverty
in accumulated situations
in the West, and so on.
And from that, we
will make case studies
of the major reactions--
London, Paris, Vienna,
Barcelona, and Chicago.
This is a comprehensive look
at some very detailed aspects
of existing transformations.
Hopefully, by the time we
get to the end of the class,
we'll be able to make
theoretical generalizations
better than the ones I've
explained to you so far.
Don't be too depressed.
The remarkable thing is
that we are building cities.
We build them, perhaps, not
as well spatially as we did
150 years ago or 300 years ago.
But there's no more cholera
because of the great invention
in 1854 in London, causing
the biggest transformation
of London by siphoning
off wastewater
on the east and west sides,
north and south of London.
All of this will
build up a story
about the complexity of
actual urban situations, which
I believe is better
than too much time
spending on abstract models.
I don't know if we'll ever
have a theory of city form
which is universally agreed
upon, able to be systematized.
Some aspects of the performance
of this field, which
are moving more and
more in this direction--
we certainly know more
about public transportation
and its engineering and
science than ever before.
We know very little
about meaning.
We build pickle-shaped
tall buildings in London
without even being able
to measure the effect.
And there are parts
of the world which
are looking to manifest urban
identity without building
the tallest building
in the world,
and a number of issues of
that kind which are currently
on the plate of urban designers.
OK.
I'll see you on Thursday.
Have a good holiday.